so we know from watching gleason that
steve is an avid tweeter and i went to
his twitter yesterday and i saw a recent
tweet which was i have no intention to
hang in there or survive I intend to
keep living a purposeful productive life
and do what I love so how much of that
mission statement that personal mission
statement is also for you first Michelle
and also for you clay with making this
film because this is not just a film
this is also your life this is your
history your world
rivers world world so Steve is a much
he's an amazing I've just I've been
looking at his Twitter feed lately too
and I think he's like turning into a
great motivational speaker and I'm not
that great of emotion a motivational
speaker but to that point I I try to
take from Steve not just hanging in
there I have a lot of days where I don't
feel like hanging in there and I have to
or don't not doing anything kind of
great so I try to take from him to
actually live a little bit harder than
I'm actually feeling like doing it
because sometimes I'm just feeling low
it's at that point I think I take I I
can model myself after Steve and what he
does and and how he has to act through
what he's going through to try a little
bit harder and do things maybe better
than I would normally I don't know what
I just said good
I I think from from me and like watching
you guys and trying to put the movie
together it was about trying to show
that determination so that same
determination that made Steve an
outstanding football player even though
he was under sized is the same thing
that I think helps them to excel and
continue you know to be a good father
and husband and so so that that strength
and that determination is so present in
his life that I think that that that's a
good representation of what must go
through his mind all the time is that
tweet talking about not not fading away
there are so many things that this film
is there's many layers to it and it has
to do about father-son has to do about
being a hero and then also you know he
gets to interview Pearl Jam so he gets
to be in the and the other seat where he
gets you know see someone that he's
idolized or a group he's idolized but
what did you want the movie not to be
because there the movie is so many
things and has many layers but what did
you when you got together I don't want
this movie to be this I mean I think one
of the things that it could easily veer
into is just a 100% kind of rosy cheery
picture of you know this sports hero and
I think you know for it to to veer into
somewhat saccharine territory would be a
real shame because one of the things
that Steve said when I first met with
him about the the film was he wanted to
show that the daily realities of what
it's like to live with ALS and the daily
realities of ALS are not rosy and cheery
all the time so you know while the film
mixes humor and and sadness and and all
these emotions and it's very dense
emotionally in that way I think it would
it would do a great injustice and and it
would be hard for people who had ALS to
watch the movie and appreciate it in
that way if it was just all rosy all the
time I was at the exact same thing I
think it would be a disservice to people
who are actually living with the disease
to just see a movie just about the rosy
parts because not everyone is as
fortunate as we are to do to interview
Pearl Jam or to you know have this
amazing team of people around us and so
I think showing the realities of our day
and being honest and is Ron honest as we
can be is more cathartic for people
watching it going through it so they can
actually you know almost feel like okay
these guys are going through this as
well and and it feels good to see other
people going through this as well as
being able to show people that are
around them
you know this is what we're going
through if you don't really understand
what we're going through so I think
that's been I think he hit it nail on
nail in the head
Michele I like what you say in the film
and that you want to be seen as a real
person you don't want to be seen as a
saint or a devil but a real person and
that's kind of what I said yeah yes or a
yeah I actually didn't hear
that part okay in terms of the editing
the footage that you that you put
together
clay when did you allow Michelle and
Steve to see how you've pieced it
together because it's interesting a
filmmaker sees one version and then the
people that the film was about it's
their life it's a totally different
version absolutely yeah I mean it was it
was pretty crucial to be able to show
Steve and Michelle a cut of the film and
multiple cuts in that we were constantly
trying to find the line of making a
responsible movie because it is so open
and honest and raw and they're so
vulnerable that we didn't want to put
out a movie that made somebody
uncomfortable to the point where we were
exploiting them against their wishes so
what we really had to do was try to you
know have a dialogue and collaborate and
so we showed you guys the movie right
before we submitted a Sundance I think
and and then as we were finishing
leading up to the festival we you know
we're talking about it all the time you
tweaked it and were their parts though
that you said no I you know because one
day rivers will see it and unless he's
already seen it and and really start to
comprehend his life there I did did I
tell you I didn't want anything in there
I think that mostly they had people
things in that I wanted to stay in I
wanted it to be I literally I wanted it
to be as real and raw as possible
so some of the things that might have
been taken out I fought to have them
back in but as it is I don't think
there's anything that's in there
at that point the the cut was I think
like two hours long as well
you know trying to trying to get it down
to time and you have to as they saying
kill your darlings in the Edit room and
there was lots of moments look we had
1300 hours of footage that were captured
over five years so there was plenty of
amazing things that had to hit the edit
room floor but yeah for the most part it
I wouldn't say that there is anything
that was just like something that was
against my wishes or something that had
to be taken out or he was very patient
though I think between Steve and I were
the biggest probably critics plus an
entire team of us who are looking out
for us and for team Gleason and he I
think he did a good job in trying to
appease everyone at the same time trying
to make the movie that he was was hired
to make this that's not an easy process
no I'm sure it's not what I found
fascinating was that Steve was not only
part subject but he was also part
interview or where he got to you know
speak to Pearl Jam and I think there was
the one scene where he was able to ask
any better about his dad yeah it was
very powerful you know some of their
songs has Steve always been inquisitive
and sort of upfront because I even saw
it with his father the the one last
interview that he did toward the movie
where he was just it seemed like he was
wasting no time he wanted certain
answers and he wasn't going to sugarcoat
them whereas other people might ease
into it and you think that als diagnosis
kind of made it like this is it and
we're doing this now what was I think
for sure that has a little bit to do
with it I'm trying to remember he's he's
changed a lot physically I mean he's
changed a lot through the diagnosis
obviously I think that Steve is able now
with what he's gone through I think
people respect that he types with his
eyes and respect that you know small
talk is really not part of his
personality anymore
so yeah I think he he's more comfortable
now and just getting to the point just
because it just for conversation alone
it takes forever to have a conversation
because he's typing one letter at a time
so I don't know if it's the als
diagnosis or it's the technology
but I think he's definitely in your
question more yeah more apt to get right
to the point
and and have a clearer the interview to
get questions he wants answered then he
probably would you know he used to talk
with lots of man's and dudes and you
know I I mean he's always been a very
like well-read and articulate guy from
what I can tell is that he's it's it's
made him more efficient in his in his
words and like he's always been
articulate but yet now it's like there's
only there's only so much time patience
overload yeah and so he's super super
efficient in his in his speech and is
able to like yeah cut right through yeah
he's got he's gotten really good at that
at being with the questions being
answered and yeah with everything I'm
like people around him or just like a
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla like his
wife I've not gotten efficient yes
whatever you he just sent me he just
sent me a text before this stick to
short answers perfect example thank
Steve clay what's your process for
writing and documentary as you're
writing something but in the same sense
it's a real thing that's happening yet
to me it's it's writing is is editing so
like the editor of a documentary is the
writer and I think that it's just you're
crafting the story out of pieces that
already exist and you're you know you're
helping to kind of craft these sound
bites and and lay out the story in
conjunction with the director as well
that just happens to be me in this
instance as well I do editing and
directing so it's not that I'm having
conversations with myself all the time
but only in the car only in the car yeah
lots of voice memos to myself but yeah I
mean it really helps to in the writing
process to have people and a sounding
board to to help
crap the story because you get lost in
it and for me those sounding boards are
Seth Gordon and Mary rolek two of our
other producers and that's just you know
they've been with me on all the the
movies that I've made
Mary's also my wife so that there's some
some overlap there but a little bit a
little bit and yeah we're just just
having that sort of that creative team
that you can bounce ideas off of and and
try to figure out what the best story
has to be told out of the pieces that
you were given now if I understand the
story correctly you heard about the
making of the film and you jumped on a
plane you know with no hesitation I
don't know if that's a correct story but
yeah do you remember what that plane
ride was like where was the baggage yeah
no storage it was a cargo plane it's
next to a goat okay friendly good
friendly good very friendly good so I I
saw this teaser trailer that these two
guys time and small and David Lee had
put together and they had been with the
family shooting for years and really
embedded themselves and becoming part of
the family so they put this teaser
trailer together I saw it and a couple
days later I jumped on a plane to go and
you know meet the family and and profess
my my love for the story and you know
immediately I just was was taken with
Steve and Michelle I felt like I knew
you guys you mostly fell in love with me
yes I we played ping-pong
almost immediately after I'm sure yes to
the house so you know just being able to
to bond and and get to know each other
better was was I think crucial but
during that flight was there any type of
should I be doing this what if they what
if it's not a match I mean what was the
what were the voices in your head at
that point honestly from being totally
candid I I did not have any of those
voices I was very excited to come and
talk to them and I felt like there was
so did a little bit of background my so
my
there has been Muhammad Ali's lawyer for
30 years and I had always been wanting
to tell a story about Muhammad and his
wife Lani and in seeing some of this
footage about Steve and Michelle I saw
some very strong parallels and I just
felt instantly even in that six minute
clip that like I knew how to tell the
story and I know that sounds perhaps
overconfident but I just wanted to go
down there and talk to them and show
them that that I was the the best person
to come on in and help bring their story
to the world and when he left what was
the conversation like I like this guy I
trust him oh I didn't really care much
about the movie part I just like them
because he played ping pong okay so I
knew like okay this guy's yeah there was
a movie crew that was figuring out the
movie I was like no I liked him I think
he I liked his look and I liked his
clothes and I liked to play ping pong
with him Oh what did I wear I don't know
she's probably using yeah probably the
same thing yeah my shoes yeah he didn't
wear them but you know what do you want
people to take away from the film even
if they're not within the ALS community
what do you want them to take away from
it so I think my favorite response of
this question because we get it quite
often is I hope that people get from it
what they need to get from it because I
think people are going through
everyone's going through something in
their lives and from talking to people
and the different ways this film has
impacted them it seems like it's
affecting people in all different ways
and they're getting all different types
of things from it so that's that's the
short and sweet answer I hope they get
what they what they need that day from
it or that week from it yeah I mean I
think we were talking before we started
rolling a little bit that I hope that
people take away a sense of the power of
the resilience of the human spirit that
there's you know no matter what kind of
hardships that people are going through
in their lives that there there are ways
to persevere and to maintain hope and so
just that perspective and doing things
that you
with the people you love having that
hope is I think very important and
something that's really Universal at
what point do you plan to show Rivers
the entire cut of a filmer he's already
watch it's a great no it's a great
question we still have to talk about it
he I'm still pretending I'm we're still
not even he must know what we're doing
here we always call it an event but I
don't think some later much later maybe
when his cousin's watch it so no plans
of yet he's four I'm thinking like
thirty two we have we have brought
together all the video journals that
Steve has recorded and we have them
organized and on a drive and you know
set aside for four rivers he loves
watching himself yeah I can I can see
why you have thirteen hundred hours of
footage from the two DPS that were
essentially living with you also acting
as part-time caregivers right right okay
so when you receive the footage of these
video are these vlogs that Steve did on
his own how was that for you how much
time was that now how much time were the
footage so of the thirteen hundred hours
I say about a little over a hundred of
it was these video journals and very
early on it became apparent that we can
use these video journals as a spine and
as a kind of device to to kind of thread
the movie together because in all those
hours there was never any really
sit-down interviews with too many people
to ask like what's going on right now
and how do you feel about it so that was
a way for Steve to essentially be doing
that all the time
here's what you know I had a statue
unveiling today this is how I feel about
it this is what happened it's cool and
so it was it was kind of a pre pre made
tool that we could use to help build the
structure of the film what we're a lot
of those vlogs shot on is I think it was
earlier so yeah a lot of it was iPhones
and the very you know some of the very
first iPhones and then it moved on to
some handycam you know like Canon JVC
kind of home video cameras what else was
there
you would know GoPros Jerry said that it
was no GoPros yeah okay lots of GoPros
once Steve cuz Steve could put it on his
when he would still control his
wheelchair he could put it on there so
lots of trips with rivers he'd film them
or like the adventures but I remember we
used to put his phone down for time
lapses and just like write a big card
like in the middle of a neighborhood and
be like this is Steve Leeson's camera
please don't steal it yeah another steve
ism is awesome ain't easy yes awesome
and easy is one of our favorite shirts
and it in the movie it stems from a time
when Steve's having one of the video
journals
two rivers and he's starting at I think
saying like it's one of the first days
he's actually watched himself in these
video journals and felt like he's
looking sick and it was really tough for
him but as he continues to talk to
rivers and this little creepy Zen he
said you know but then he said son this
is not gonna be easy but it's gonna be
awesome and I'm gonna be here for you
you know as long as I can and so that's
kind of that's where it stemmed from
right after that
but you really got got me good I'm just
like sitting there like please don't you
came out firing I'll tell you what
there's first question and I was just
looking at a Twitter feed this morning
just kind of like oh man we're so
different